[Musique]
bonsoir les amis quel silence
peut-être que tous les enfants dorment
déjà ce soir ce serait trop beau mon
cher nounours mais peut-être bien que
nicolas et pimprenelle cho patrons ne
fait pas de bruit
je descends voir sur la pointe et si son
départ par la personne non
mais non ils ne dorment pas pimprenelle
ou nicolas c'est une blague
ils se sont cachés ou êtes-vous ou
[Musique]
le haut qu'est-ce qui se pose est finie
opel a dit à leo quoi ma maladie cachez
vous vous ne verrez pas nounours ce soir
où la mosquée vous avez dû être piaf
n'ont pas beaucoup non ça prenait un
coca cola dénudées mention voulons hall
où les enfants c'est nicolas adam il m'a
jeté des boules de melon il m'appelait
type renault et m'a tiré la langue elle
m'a jeté un verre d'eau et bien vous
pouvez vous cachez vous vous êtes
disputé sept relais je crois qu'il vaut
mieux que vous ne voyez preuve ce soir
[Musique]
on est gentil maintenant c'est juste et
rapide
et puis tu vois on va se coucher tout de
suite vous ne vous disputerez plus c'est
promis c'est promis ne nous laissait
soir
plus jamais on essaiera de l'eau ont
reçu
[Musique]
non
je suis bien content bonne nuit lui
n'ose pas me faire mon bien les pompiers
bonsoir papa maman j'ai éteint les
lumières
re chez le petit au fond
j'ouvre la fenêtre je sens andry les
encens peut-être sont endormis
je reprends bonus
l'eau jaune
chaumont
[Musique]
nicolas mas prod
le
je vous ou ti à dos
[Musique]
j'espère que vous aussi les enfants vous
ne vous disputerez plus pas trop ce soir
tous les enfants sortent autant mieux
nounours car nous allons leur apporter
une belle surprise qui leur fera très
très plaisir quoi dont patron pitt mois
dans le creux de l'oreille
youpi que je suis content patron quand
je suis content et nicolas et
pimprenelle qu'ils vont être heureux et
bien allant vite chercher cette surprise
en route fidèle compagnon mains nues des
enfants
faites pour eve youpi fait pour eux
[Musique]